du kannst dich entscheiden entscheide
dich mensch ich habe gesagt du musst
dich entscheiden weil du heute sehe ich
noch das moderne sun jedoch das
mittelalter ähnliches habe ich habe ja
gesagt ja ich mache jetzt erstmal so die
version sei nicht die genaue größe aber
ich weiß schon so ungefähr wie moskaus
sich für noch so gestört dass ich so
viel erde habe jetzt gar keine auf einen
stick viel
ja das ist dass diese ressourcen gehen
schneller nicht als man gucken kann
schneller weg als man bis 13 kanal 24
findet aber woher holen muss irgendwas
abbauen muster oder du hast du bestimmt
erde wenn du da
ich habe aber ich habe ein bisschen er
da hab ich habe so viel tannen stämme
also ich hab unendliche unendliche
übertrieben oder vier holz ja was will
ja kein schwein wollen wir das triple
her pendelt
da habe ich eine rolle dabei mein bett
zu kräften ja einfach dämlich aus deinem
haus nehmen ich vor mir und ich wohne
jetzt hast du gehört
durch einfach an social work beheizten
schneefälle haben in diesem land in
diesem keller hier was wir hier spielen
habe ich irgendwie schon gelungen zehn
workbench oder so verkraftet weil ich
immer wieder an so stehen lassen dreimal
gold dreimal des weges und dafür dass
gut das kann man immer für irgendwelche
sachen benutzen und weiß was ich kann
heute und an freien stellen schaffen wie
es mich noch nichts und gute nacht bis z
ich laufe da hin du brauchst du brauchst
so lange da denken wir sogar da kann ich
noch ein bisschen rum laufen dann auf
einmalig zwischen bett und noch ein huhn
getötet jetzt komme ich gerade ins dorf
schon rein deutsche stürmer den treffer
weg jetzt mache ich die tür öffnen bin
ich immer aus drin und liege im bett
jetzt wird es gerade bei mir dunkel und
genauer auswählen
nein ich bin besser als jetzt gehts
statt sondern wird mit streuen so war
auch okay ich schreibe es einfach um
ich wollte damit angreifen reporter der
sich weg möchte ich unbedingt so eine
tolle energies machen
da haben die monster am fließband ich
wollte es müsste mich gestellt haben
der schwächste schaublatt wünsche ich
mir so ich habe zwei schaufeln ich will
mich ich laufe jetzt noch da ganz hinten
sich 46 erde hat mein himmel so komische
teilweise da hier sowohl baulich erde ab
ich glaube jetzt einfach nach der ganz
hinten dann möchtest du läuft jetzt auch
schon wieder eine hürde werden so derbe
viele höhlen
das ist ja nicht normal das ist gar
nicht nur mal du oder einer höhle hier
ist erst an der oberfläche greift direkt
beim zu man soll ja nicht nein sagen
einem geschenkten gaul der pasok
schmerzhafter luxe drin
das sind beispielsweise hätten hier
richtig da gibt es auch nur hier bei
amazon jetzt vorbestellen zum
sonderpreis von unglaublich
unschlagbaren 999 euro und 69
also ich mache und ich haben einen
rabatt die wendeltreppe gar nicht kannst
du gar nicht warum baumhaus wollte man
das braucht oben auf einem berg drauf
ist dann ja wohl eick ist so was machen
die da vorne war ich jetzt das ab weil
da sieht so schön aus so muss ich auf
jeden fall erstmal erde wegnehmen wenn
man braucht nur dieses komische bio mehl
das komische keine ahnung tannenbaum
groß bio ist mal richtig weit reisen
glaube ich mehr heißt noch mal weit man
springen natürlich den kompletten server
aber es ist relativ egal
nun hat sie
eine wendeltreppe die muss her
ich weiß nicht wo ich die stades datei
ist der der welt gespeichert habe von
daher auch wenn die wert verloren geht
so traurig bittet guckt danach und
speicher alles schöner ich mache das
jetzt erst mal auf dieser aufnahme schön
abschwächen
dann hat sich das
der corner ist einer der trends zählen
so zweite schaufel jetzt noch hier alles
andere wegtragen dann habe ich mir ganz
ganz viel erde
die werde ich damit mein haus packen
damit so eine art dann wohne ich über
den anderen über ungespielt an ehe das
ist auf dem berg ist nicht möglich
der ist nicht möglich man einfach ein
ganz ganz ganz ganz hohen turm gar nicht
was da passiert dann aber ich kann dann
auf dich herab gucken einfach nur aus
dem grund bist du gern mal dass du meine
treppenhaus probieren wir sagt ob die
haye ist schnee runter gefallen nach
sodass ins studium
das heißt sie wird immer schneiden in
meinem haus ist egal
weihnachts feeling
das schütze auch mit einer vorne also
ein großer baum an meine zuschauer ganz
viel zu selten werden schnee benutzt
beide mögen sie nicht
ja diese attacke sieht scheiße aus ihr
stehen und diese blöden bäume ein
bisschen schnee muss sein die welt noch
schnee du kannst dich sagen ein bisschen
schnee hält die welt voll dann
entscheiden was kann ich kann alles
konnte mein tempo rufst du ich bin im
arsch der welt und im arsch von der welt
du meinst richtig im popo so richtig so
richtig richtig tief drin durch das
alles raus aus braun ist okay das waren
zu viele informationen
ich baue hier einfach so ein bisschen
weiter ab so thema wer jetzt ganz gut
thema conti konzern ein bisschen was
über die eben dass wir hatten eben
angesprochen mal vergeben bis 23 folgen
haben wir mal weibliche zocker wie geht
es generell ausgeht generell beim
bayerischen schlecht bei dir ab erzählen
mal privat
das gleiche war ja die heiß zu machen
haben
bei eisglätte und krawatte momentan
touristen
noch zwei skelette und reinheim herz das
heißt ich werd ich mit kapiteln typ so
also vernünftigen mitteln kommt das was
du dich privat ist also alles daran so
privat ja es ist
ich möchte nichts privates hier auf
youtube sagen ich rede von deiner mutter
die bei project wird fragen wie es geht
uns jedes zu privaten gestellt sagt
blöden skelette bei albert fast habt ihr
denn für komplexe also ich mich
interessiert ja mal ich hab eine
schallplatte weltkrieg abgeschossen
man kriegt eine schallplatte wenn es
laut eingriffe abschießt echt ja ich
habe an jetzt bin ich zum beispiel die
ag und bobo als gleichzeitig die stars
so jetzt noch kohle kriegen wir schon
erfahrung ich bin schon 29 wenn ich
jetzt stelle das so ärgerlich hilfen für
seine hässliche marmor höhne und hier
geht es bald direkt wieder raus aber
noch kurz die ärzte ab ich weiß zwar
immer noch nicht wofür ich die brauchen
weil wir immer eure kommentare leben
weil wir das gerade als ein stück
aufnehmen
aber ich möchte noch mal mein weg dahin
zu ist nicht das braucht herausfinden
mit welchen wir sonst noch so einsame
nachkommen so andreu auch nicht wenn ich
schon einmal hab ich habe mit an bord
oben auf meinen bauch meinberg besitzen
warte was hab ich hier gerade gefunden
was ist das was ich mir wünsche
jetzt eine eisentür mit so komischen
musik cobblestone das sieht aus wie
dungeon alltag oft erstmal an erstmal
anbieter dschungel wo bist du denn wie
kraus koordinaten - 309 - 324 und bäumen
40 94 9
ich würde ich würde das lieber mit
rüstungen erforschen das ist ein dungeon
ich habe eine halbe rüstung weit ich
gehen runter ich mitkommen angeschafftes
hier sind drei mops bonner ich mehr wird
es anderes mal machen ja dass die mobs
war natürlich auch nicht kaputt machen
weil das könnte eine schöne wasser
sparen ja ich möchte sie aber trotzdem
erst mal aus leicht mit stehen ja okay
wie gesagt ich habe noch zwei herzen und
ich möchte nicht dass meine level hier
so nahe stehen
deswegen werden wir das ein anderes mal
machen ich werde aber erst mal so ein
tempel in bonn
von wegen hier müssen wir mal
vorbeigucken mehr kann als waypoint
setzen fällt mir auf way point höhle mit
der minimap waypoint ja jetzt habe ich
einen rappen komische höhle und jetzt
hab ich noch anderthalb herzen und wird
man erst mal eine schöne verrottetes
fleisch essen
eine schön vielleicht weil dieses schild
verdutzte fehler
bartko schrank error ich laufe einfach
darum herum gesprochen
es gibt sie mehr so ich werde jetzt
erstmal haus bauen
wer erst mal wieder oben gucken was ich
hier schon alles sei ja ich kann man
ganz bei dir vorbei kommen so habe den
folgen oder so komme ich auf die idee
mir auszubauen
der chip im ball ist weg
du musst dich meine quelle durch also
geht die treppe hoch aber ganz hoch
nicht nur diese nicht an dieser
einstellung der erste einigung ist sein
du musst an weiter an der seite weiter
hoch und dann muss durch die quelle
durch und so naja ich bin auf dem weg so
die ich ihr die treppe hoch die sich
erst mal ein bett und alles hier ist
eine quelle das muss aber noch schöner
machen
das ist ja erstmal die brille sowie
varna erst bauen blb hast du knochen
muss jetzt hier am rand hoch hüpfen ja
am berg an hast du hast du knochen ich
würde gern diesen baum hier wachsen
lassen